es war ein tag unter dem motto endlich
zwölfter märz 2018 ein halbes jahr nach
der bundestagswahl unterschreiben union
und spd den koalitionsvertrag und waren
wohl selbst ein wenig skeptisch vor
allem die spd bestand darauf zur
halbzeit noch einmal bilanz zu ziehen
und die umfasst nun über 80 seiten
groko bewertet kroko kein wunder dass
das fahren sie positiv ausfällt
doch wie gut steht es tatsächlich um die
arbeit der bundesregierung was wurde
erreicht in den wichtigen
politikbereichen der zukunft klima
digitalisierung und migration
karl berning ist politikwissenschaftler
an der uni mainz seine halbzeitbilanz
fällt weniger euphorisch aus das thema
klimaschutz rückte bei der regierung
erst macht in vielen protesten in den
fokus da macht es sich die
bundesregierung sehr leicht weil es
waren zu anderen zeiten aufgesetzt
der plan wurde sehr schwammig formuliert
und damit kann die bundesregierung hier
eigentlich ein gutes ergebnis erzielen
obwohl tatsächlich noch nichts umgesetzt
wird also es gibt ein
klimaschutzprogramm 2030 und es gibt ein
kohleausstieg gesetz das auch noch
verabschiedet werden müssen aber alles
das war in dem detail nicht im
koalitionsvertrag beschrieben
beim thema digitalisierung blieb man
hinter den erwartungen zurück
digitalisierung war im koalitionsvertrag
mit vielen versprechen und mit tollen
ideen entwickelt worden
manches wurde davon durchaus umgesetzt
sowie ein digital packte schulen
manches wurde aber auch abgegeben so
eine flächendeckende digitale versorgung
da sind jetzt die netzbetreiber
zuständig beim thema migration hakt es
vor allem bei der zusammenarbeit mit
anderen ländern das war das thema vor
der letzten bundestagswahl
hier wurden viele gesetze auf den weg
gebracht
das zentrale thema in der
flüchtlingskrise war allerdings die
verteilung die europäische verteilung
hier steht noch abstimmung aus so unter
anderem auch die reform des dublin
verfahrens die bundesregierung ist also
kein einserschüler den schulnoten
übersetzt gibt es beim klima gerade so
eine 2 bei digitalisierung und migration
eine 3 und wie fällt das gesamtfazit aus
allgemein wird man könnte man sagen dass
so etwa 60 bis 70 prozent der vorhaben
umgesetzt wurden beziehungsweise
angestoßen worden
aber ob diese in den maßnahmen
tatsächlich auch wirkung zeigen ob die
opposition oder gesellschaft mit diesen
maßnahmen einverstanden als insbesondere
stichwort klima das bleibt aus deswegen
ist durchaus der regierung ja ein
gemischtes zeugnis auszustellen und die
gespräche über das streitthema
grundrente wurden von anfang dieser
woche auf sonntag verschoben
vielleicht wollte man sich einfach nicht
die bilanz verhageln
[Musik]